today we've curated 50 games 18 titles
with exclusivity and 15 world premieres
[Music]
[Music]
world premiere
for the first time ever on Xbox Kingdom
Hearts
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome from Bethesda Game
Studios todd howell we thought we'd give
all of you an exclusive world premiere
first look at fallout 76
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome from Capcom producer Matt
Walker and director hey Aki it's uno has
it that I wait for ya for this
thank you so much DMC is back
[Music]
the assistants
to hit every single bump in the road my
true
and now I'm proud to introduce the
creation of a brand new Microsoft studio
the initiative undead labs playground
games and for the fourth new studio it's
my personal honor to welcome Ninja
Theory to Microsoft studio and yes we've
got a fifth studio to announce
compulsion games please help me in
welcoming all of our new studios please
welcome from playground games Ralph
Fulton I am excited to show you the
world premiere of Forza horizon for say
a beautiful historic Britain let's join
Rebecca she is enjoying the summer and
her highly customized Nissan Silvia you
play with the entire community and that
means the other drivers you'll meet in
the game will be real people with all
the variety spontaneity and fun that
real people bring world premiere I'll
take that sniper on top
back out
all right let me try to get that tank
off you take the capital back I think
we're ready three two one go
world premiere
[Music]
hi I'm Chris Avallone and I'm excited to
be working with tech land to create the
world of dying light - dying light -
will be the first at it genre where your
choices
have genuine consequences in the game
itself from how it looks how it plays to
the events that occur everything in the
game world can change based on your
decisions let's say you choose to carry
out the peacekeepers order one way or
another
[Music]
after this you will start seeing a
significant change in the city as access
to the water supply allowed the
peacekeepers to bring stability and
develop the area and by the way this is
just what happens in the day at night
well things tend to get a lot darker and
the amazing team at the coalition is
working hard to bring you our most
ambitious Gears of War title yet Gears v
[Applause]
today we shared our commitment to giving
you the freedom to dub discover and play
all of the great new games coming to
Xbox game pass today we showcased more
games than we ever have before 50 games
18 titles with exclusivity and 15 world
for me as well today
we shared our most diverse gaming
portfolio in every measure from breath
and art style genre and culture's range
and subject and setting scale and story
and scope and creative visions and every
one of these plays that's due on Xbox
[Music]
the world of gaming in this is on and
historic growth path where the
increasing number of gamers is met with
the increasing creative power of game
developers in this significant moment we
are constantly challenging ourselves
where can we take gaming next
so choose the games you want to play
there are worlds to be saved heroes to
be made and legends to be come together
thanks and have a great
in 2077 they voted my city the worst
place to live in America main issues sky
high rate of violence and more people
living below the poverty line than
anywhere else
[Music]
however greatly